good evening everyone I'm no lensy I
teach Classics and history here at Yale
and I am charged with the honor and the
pleasure of introducing our speaker for
this evening Professor Clifford Ando of
the University of
Chicago I should like to begin with a
few words however about the names sake
of our event mik Ivanovic
roev tomorrow the 10th of November will
Mark the 154 anniversary of RV's birth
in zamir in what is today Southwestern
Ukraine about 140 km west of keev
therefore a place troubled greatly by
violence inflicted by the state of
Russia a state in which rosev grew up
and in fact was educated under the
Zars he studied Classics in ancient
history at keev and St Petersburg where
he went on to serve as professor of
Latin for 20 years down to 1918 in the
upheaval of the Russian Revolution rosev
who opposed the Bolsheviks was forced to
flee Russia and eventually landed in
Madison Wisconsin in
1920 after teaching there for 5 years he
moved to New Haven to take up a
professorship at Yale and remained there
down to his retirement in
1944 he lived on until 1952 when he
passed away in New Haven and is now
buried in the Grove Street Cemetery
where a group of us went today um to lay
a wreath on his tomb rosv was a
brilliant scholar who revolutionized the
study of the ancient world in ways that
have only really come into clearer focus
in contemporary America or the
Contemporary world at the moment he
combined an interest in archaeology and
uh in archaeological fieldwork with a
passion for economic and cultural
history his two greatest works the
social and economic history of the Roman
Empire published first in 1926 and the
social and economic history of the
helenistic World published in 194 41
were both gold mines of information
produced well before the information
revolution a voracious reader of
countless languages and an avid
afficionado of quantitative methods he
set the Benchmark for source-based
historical investigations in second in
the second quarter of the 20th century
rosopa published some 12 monographs and
countless articles displaying a
breathtaking knowledge of ancient
history from early Greece through late
Rome and from Africa to Gaul to Egypt to
the Crimea to Syria it was his field
workor that uncovered The Fortress city
of dur europas parts of which are now on
display in the Yale University Art
Gallery although his methods fell out of
favor in the mid 20th century in large
part due to the unmistakable imprint
left by his bitter experience of the
Russian Revolution on his scholarly
views Rosa's taste for big data and for
the intermingling of textual and
material evidence have come roaring back
in the scholarly presence in addition to
his scholarly works his excavation finds
and his methodological Innovations rosv
continues to impact yields into lectual
environment through this lecture series
the annual Mika rosev lecture and
colloquium was made possible through a
bequest by his widow the late Sophie
kitki rosv for the last 16 years we've
been able to welcome some of the most
distinguished researchers in the field
of ancient history as lecturers in the
series and to sponsor a symposium the
following morning including equally
distinguished Scholars to comment on the
lecture and engage in learned dialogue
with the lecturer so that will occur
tomorrow morning beginning at 900 a.m.
in Phelps Hall
401 our speaker this evening Clifford
Ando is the David B and Clara F Stern
distinguished service Professor he's
professor of Classics and history at uh
the University of Chicago where he is
chair and has been for the last six
years Ando studied at Princeton
University and then at the University of
Michigan where he completed his PhD in
1996 he's the editor of the monographic
series Empire and after with the
University of Pennsylvania press senior
editor of the brenmar classical review
editor of no a journal on the formation
of knowledge and is on the editorial
board of seven other journals or
monographic series he has held visiting
professorships or temporary appointments
at 14 universities across the United
States Europe and New Zealand he has
held numerous fellowships including the
ACLS Burkhart fellowship and currently
an neh scholarly editions and
translations grant for his project on
Roman statutes which I believe is the
source for some of what he'll talk about
this evening Anda was the author of
seven monographs including Imperial
ideology and provincial loyalty in the
Roman Empire published with the
University of California press in 2000
which won the Charles Goodwin Award of
Merit in 2003 from the then American
philological Association he's the editor
of 14 books including the Oxford
handbrook of Roman law and society and
the first volume of the forthcoming
Cambridge world history of rights which
will appear next year he's published
over 120 articles and 60 reviews and
short notes he is in brief boundless in
energy but also in range and in
brilliance just as to range Ando covers
in his published research Fields as
diverse as the Roman Republic Roman
imperial history late Antiquity Latin
and Greek literature the history of law
the history of religion the history of
philosophy and the philosophy of law the
philosophy of language and the history
of knowledge and I could go
on his work has had a major impact on
the field in at least four respects
first and foremost Ando has played a
crucial role arguably the crucial role
in bringing Classics and ancient history
into dialogue with philosophy particular
particularly the philosophy of Mind
epistemology and
phenomenology this was clear already in
his first monograph which covered
remarkable range of time and breadth of
sources and situated these into a
sociological framework constructed um
especially around the Frankfurt School
and its theory of Law and reason within
the life
world second Ando has helped make
Classics in ancient history a serious
interlocutor with Scholars of Law and
government his recent work on
citizenship in the ancient world
particularly in the Roman world has
helped us to rethink our contemporary
world where questions of citizenship and
state belonging are deeply relevant and
deeply implicated in discourses of
inclusion and
exclusion third ando's serious work on
language not just at the level of
philology a field in which he is expert
but more importantly in the realm of
philosophy of language have helped us to
comprehend the way in which linguistic
habits and practices shape the way that
we think and reason and thus the way
that we shape our
world but finally his work as a
coordinator of people of ideas of
information make him a hub around which
so much that is happening in ancient
history legal history and intellectual
history is turning at the moment the
project on Roman statutes for example
seeks to bring together all the evidence
that we have for positive law in the
Republic and early Imperial periods a
task as gargantuan as it is frustrating
given the anzing but fragmentary nature
of the material I think it's fair to say
that there is no other scholar working
today with the breath of expertise and
connections to make this project work
without Clifford Ando in our world the
study of ancient history of antiquity of
the history of knowledge and of religion
would be greatly impoverished which is
why it brings me great pleasure this
evening to be able to offer you a chance
to partake in the riches that he has to
offer to eny enjoy the learning and uh
the breath of knowledge that Professor
Ando can bring to us and so without
further Ado I would ask us all to join
in welcoming Clifford Ando to speak to
us tonight on the subject of Empire's
law the Roman state in the 2 Century
BCE
so thank you no for that quite amazing
introduction so I'm going to I'm going
to try to be uh disciplined today
because I I I realized that the version
of this lecture was sent to the to the
people who are going to lead the
conversation tomorrow and I I I'm going
to have to suppress my natural urge just
to like run off and and and improvise um
because I think it's most fair to the
people who' have actually already read
the text and are going to be responding
to the text that they have received to
um uh to adhere closely to to the
document I'll try to be good in a way
that I'm often not um so I want to start
also in addition to thanking n to thank
the department of Classics for this
extraordinary
invitation I spent a great deal of time
in graduate school um reading the
prestige works of ancient history the
way you will as a kind of person
entering a field so I spent a great deal
of time reading Simon brunt and Miller
and then Hopkins or Finley and Hopkins I
should say and then you know eek and
nicolay and so on all of whom have
something like a substantial and legible
pedigree worthwhile reflecting on at
this moment because the chairs of the
Roman history chair in Oxford and the
chair of ancient history at Cambridge
are vacant at the same time I think for
the first time
ever and I also spent a lot of time
reading rosf and uh McMullen um who did
not so far as I could tell as far as I
could piece them together have a
pedigree that I could understand I
couldn't understand their educational
histories or why they wrote what they
wrote in a way that it's sort of
intelligible to me why the other people
did what they
did I worked on the past on topics that
align closely with Central themes in
rosto's work um today's lecture I
confess does not um but I want to tr pay
tribute as I begin to the quite
extraordinary sequence of ancient
historians who've taught here and that
includes not simply rosv and Ramsey
McMullen whom I
miss I've spent a lot of time in sitting
in the attakus cafe being told by Ramsey
something like will you get everything
wrong when you he almost all
conversations begin with something like
Ramsey remarking on a paper I'd recently
sending by saying something like Cliff
when you say X or frequently when you
say when you say the Romans say I want
to know which Romans and then I'm sure
many of you had conversations like this
with Ramsey McMullen and of course also
John Matthews and nol himself who also
works in many fields of ancient history
and I think brings a distinct respect
both for evidence and method to all the
fields in which he
works oh
wait I think I have to move the
cursor there we go how EX
exting um so what I'm going to do today
is um uh start by talking a little bit
about uh some I think characteristic
myth that underg the study of Roman law
um in a written version of this I I I I
talk about more of them if only because
it's sometimes taking out a kind of a
truism of a field and holding it up to
the light is um well I mean for if
you're a nerd kind of hilarious um you
can especially people outside the field
of Roman law could could well ask
themselves you know as a kind of
anthropological matter did I did you
realize you were in a you were in a
university with people who believe this
sort of thing um and then I'm going to
spend a little bit of time as you will
in an ancient history talk uh in making
a set of empirical claims about what
evidence we actually
have for something um and then I'm going
to talk about the moment when something
like the vernacular narrative which I'm
going to try to disprove came into being
and talk briefly about
why people believe what they do about
Roman law before in the end making a
whole bunch of Bora claims about what
actually happened in the second century
Republic um which as I was remarking to
Seth um um
are up to a point disconnected from my
empirical claims and have the great
virtue by being so broad as as broad as
they are of being I think um probably
not provable but not falsifiable either
which is a you know a good thing for a
lecture
so um let me just start then by talking
briefly about what I take to be um two
discreet myths that undergird vernacular
histories of Roman
law the first the Romans produced
complex written statutes in a continuous
tradition from at least 510
BCE and second prior to the development
of the so-called formulary system the
civil law was administered by pontiffs
but probably also by magistrates POS
postive law rested on the 12 tables but
procedure had been specified by
subsequent statutes except that these
statutes seems themselves to have been
laid out to have laid out the positive
law that they
regulated I'll take these in
turn first regarding the history of
Roman legislation there have been
several attempts to catalog mostly from
Livy um Roman laws chronologically of
which the most influential modern effort
is that by joavan rotondi after a simply
phenomenal and extended introduction
that covers all aspects of the
production of legislation rotondi offers
lists of statutes according to genre as
here section two laws de
proon followed by a catalog that
provides for each item ancient
testimonia a quick summary of the Law's
supposed content followed by references
to research tools on matters of detail
and
context the format of the modern catalog
by Maran elster is very similar albeit
her representation of the data is much
Fuller it's in that sense that star's
work is much closer to a standalone
resource to give you this some idea of
the scale of the Enterprise as it is um
mapped by these modern research tools
Marian elster cataloges 231 laws of the
so-called middle Republic alone from 366
to 134 4
BCE the the Tiny Prints not a deliberate
Act of ambiguation um none of this data
is relevant to what will follow um
except in if you were writing some sort
of history of of the Roman novel we'll
get back to
that second regarding the history of
Roman civil law in the chapter in the
first chapters of book four of his
institutes gaas offers a brief
idiosyncratic history of some aspect of
Roman
procedure in particular gaas describes
five legal actions that he terms Legos
oon statutory
actions um as
follows the actions that the Ancients
had in use were called statutory actions
either because they were created by
statutes since of course the edicts of
the preacher by which many actions had
been introduced were not yet in use or
because they were framed in the words of
the statutes themselves and were
therefore treated as immutable
even as the statutes
were whence it was held that a man who
when suing for the cutting down of his
vines used the word vines in his claim
lost his case because he ought to have
said trees seeing that the law of the 12
tables on which his action for cutting
down his Vines lay spoke of cutting down
trees in
general now gaas is more or less our
only source for pre- formulary procedure
and his account is as partial as it is
is
tantalizing it's a cautionary tale about
both our knowledge but also their
knowledge of law before the 2 Century
BCE that we know next to nothing about
the law that principally affected the
change from the statutory actions to the
formulary procedure I refer to what the
Romans called The Lex iua date Unknown
about which rotundi himself says to this
law is attributed the introduction of
formulary procedure but it is impossible
to determine its precise content or its
impact
now I will close um I will say more
before I close about the Lex itia and
the 12 tables but in brief my claim is
that gaas received two Traditions about
early Roman law one concerned the 12
tables the other concern the so-called
statutory actions what we witness in the
opening paragraphs of book
four is his attempt to allow for both of
these Traditions to be operative at the
same
time we should not believe
either instead in order to understand
what the Romans were doing when they
invented themselves as creatures of law
we need to abandon our own longing for
knowledge that we cannot have which has
induced a kind of
credulity that we would tolerate in no
other field of inquiry we meaning here
especially historians of law not not the
the good citizens of
Classics and examine instead the context
in which these Roman speculations were
made more on this theme as we we go
along and finally before I turn to the
substance of my talk I want to pay
tribute to what I think is one of the
greatest books of Roman history of the
20th century namely Arnold Toy's
Hannibal
Legacy today if toin is cited at all is
it is as an Exemplar of error in regard
to the history of land use in
Italy but this was not a major concern
for toin be on the contrary his interest
lay in the form of the Roman state
and his thesis simply stated might be
that Roman had gmany and Italy prior to
the SEC prior to the first Punic War
took a specific form distinctive both
within the ancient Mediterranean and
indeed within the history of Federal
structures known in the world at the
time the wars with Carthage Rome's
engagement with the helenistic world
more generally brought Rome into
competition with states of a very
different form and in order to beat them
and in consequence of defeating them
them Rome itself was
transformed in short power existing in
mimetic relation to that which it
resists through competition with
helenistic powers Rome itself became a
helenistic kingdom and yet it preserved
both Public Law structures in Italy and
Republican forms of politics
domestically that were increasingly at
odds with the scale of state power and
the political economics of Mediterranean
Empire Hannibal's Legacy traces the
history of this dissonant and its
effects on Myriad aspects of Roman
social and economic
relations this is not the place to
assess toin be's achievement but I
should like at the very least to insist
that one give his argument it's due it
was not simple nor was it
falsifiable the conclusion of this paper
will try to take up the challenge that
he laid before the
field so the evidence that we have for
for Roman law part one statute and NL is
of course completely wck that I correct
that I was inspired to this project by
essentially tracing out patterns and
reading and rereading and rereading and
rereading the Corpus of epigraphically
preserved Roman
laws now it's said and I've done that
work for you so none of you has to said
I
so you're
welcome it's a truism of scholarship on
Roman legal thought and on Roman culture
more generally that the jurists were
like their compatriots in having a deep
respect for
history I've written along these lines
myself with a caveat that I've argued
that the jurists and Roman theorists
more generally consistently assembled
historical data in order to argue recent
practice has precedence over Hy
Antiquity that is why as each successive
generation of jurists wrote commentaries
on earlier commentaries on earlier
commentaries it became unnecessary to
cite the words of
Statute actions at law were available in
respect of statutes based on recent acts
of application and interpretation and
these were largely available in
contemporary language the contrast with
Athens where the wording of the original
statute had to be cited um in court
could not be
stronger despite this interpretive
position
with regard to the Roman jurist and
their respect for the past even a
conventional history like that of Aldos
SC so everyone else insisted I mean
basically all of the scholars think that
Roman jurist and the Romans in general
like to preserve the past it's something
about most myor and crap like that and
despite despite their despite our
insistence that the Romans in valued the
past and they valued precedent and so on
even people like Aldo scavone has to
admit that their knowledge of academic
legal writing before the '90s BCE was
close to
non-existent he
says despite I'll start with a second
despite this let's skip the first
paragraph despite this tendency of the
whole course of Republican jurist
Prudence until quintus muus later jurist
would preserve only a vague and blurry
memory in the body of legal literature
that survived to the present day the
thesis and doctrines of authors prior to
quintus mushes are explicitly cited on
no more than about 15 occasions at all
in very few of these references SCT a
direct suggest a direct reading of the
original
texts my ambition today is to reveal a
similar pattern regard with regard to
knowledge by persons in the 2 century
B.C of earlier law and then to pose some
questions about the conclusions we might
draw and the speculations we might make
on the basis of this
pattern now I have never read a book or
an article that reflects on the
historical data about the the history of
Roman legislation that is contained
within the legislation
itself but the writers of Roman laws
knew a lot about Roman law they
understood that any given piece of
legislation intervened in a landscape a
social world that was regulated by and
conformed itself to Prior
legislation so for example the first
extent Roman statute The Lex reparum of
122 BCE cites Three Laws The Lex rubria
is very likely the statute of
1232 that authorized the foundation of
the colony of Carthage and is therefore
Gren and date The Lex ceria is a law on
magisterial malens of 149 BC and The Lex
junor is unknown outside two references
to it in this text but the fact that
it's cited after the Lex cernia strongly
suggests that it postdates that
law in short
The Lex reparum cites no law earlier
than 149
BCE the picture is similar if we turn to
the lexaria of 111
BC Beyond some generic references to
situations that were created by prior
enactments of the people in lines 15 and
29 the lexaria makes reference to four
named
statutes yeah Alex
sempronia Alex rubria
Alex Livia and a sensorial law of Lucius
kilus matelis and ganus demissus and
heab
barbas The Lex pronia de agaria dates to
123 BCE namely a law of gaas graus that
in large measure reactivated a law of
his brother Tiberius from a decade
earlier The Lex rubria on the foundation
of Carthage dates as we have seen to 122
BC The Lex Livia is the law of 146 BCE
that appointed a senatorial commission
to assist skipp amanus in the
organization of Africa and Lucius kilus
matelis and Gus Demus aino barbus were
censors in 115
BC in other words the lexaria cites no
statute earlier than 146
[Music]
BCE the pattern holds if one continues
the analysis in this form throughout the
entire Corpus of existing Roman statutes
I cannot promise that I caught every
citation but the ones relevant to this
project are probably that in the Lex
pinkis proris of 100 BCE referring to a
law of Marcus porus KO of unknown date
but almost Pro very very likely
contemporaneous with the law in
pretorian provinces itself and a
citation of a so-called Lex Loria and
the tablet of
heraclea now we have a number of later
references to something called The Lex
Loria a law of the same name is cited by
plotus which seems anomalous the content
of the Lex Loria cited in chapter 84 of
the flavy Municipal is so different that
Michael Crawford has speculated that the
name used in the tablet of caraca is a
mistake now bracketing this problematic
case the pattern in the totality of
subsequent legislation holds no certain
reference is ever made in an extent
Roman legislation to a statute passed
before 14 passed before 149 BC and no
reference at all can even plaus imp
plausibly be reconstructed so as to
refer to a statute before 200 100
BC you can probably tell where I'm going
with this
argument my claim is going to be that no
one before the first century give or
take ever mentions a statute written
before the hannibalic war nor reports of
course if you don't cite it you can't
report the words of such a
statute but let me proceed step by
step the next genre of evidence I want
to take up is step is oratory although I
focus on reports about orators of the 2
Century BC I should say a word about the
few reports we have about earlier
writers substantively it makes no
difference to my case since the reported
fragments have almost nothing to do with
law but in the sole case that does or
might that is to say this fragment of
sensor not only does 250 years separate
the event from its first so-called
testimonium but the anecdote itself
supposedly on the occasion of his
holding the censorship for a second time
around 80 years of age is completely
implausible that said so I mean so I
think it's clear that the entire event
is just made up that neither of the
people neither valious Maximus um nor
Plutarch knew anything about this um but
that isn't even important what is
interesting um is that the elaboration
of the legend does illustrate a pattern
that interests me for what it's worth
the story as it's related by valerious
Maximus reports only a speech before the
people but two generations later um the
story had become one about public law
hence in Plutarch right um they voted he
passed a
law the two testimonia thus illustrate a
pattern of very considerable historical
importance for all that the testimonia
amount to lies and they are lies it's
clear neither of Maximus nor Plutarch
had a reliable source they are not
individually drawing on a tradition that
reported a contio and the passage of a
law such that valerious Maximus
selectively mentions the assembly and
Plutarch mentions the law the sorts of
arguments that people make using shitty
evidence like this on the contrary the
Romans came to want to see themselves as
a people whose life had been regulated
by law aino and in each retelling the
past came to resemble the story story
that the Romans
needed why this occurred and when it
occurred is an important historical
explanandum now allow me to be precise
about what I am arguing about the
evidence of the 2
Century it is not that political oratory
did not discuss matters of law the
fragments of the 2 Century orators
frequently concern
legislation but none of the orators is
represented none of them is ever
represented I think as arguing for or
against the passage of a law or for that
matter arguing for or against a
particular political decision or for or
against any policy decision by means of
the citation of archaic or republican
law mid-republican law indeed none of
them ever names an historical statute
let alone regards a contemporary problem
as potentially regulated by earlier law
or even analogous to a situation
that might be potentially regulated by
earlier
law it might be useful to situate this
pattern in respect of legal history
within a broader pattern of both
attitudes to history and normativity and
within kind of ways of talking about
history and Norm in history and
normativity at the
time I think this
slide offers
the sum total of references to custom to
one's betters or the greaters I.E the
mayores and the full roster of exemplary
stories in echin secondary oratory down
to about
120 which is not to say that later
literature the later literature we have
does not attribute relevant usage to
texts of the 2 Century BC but when it's
through jellus for example that a second
century orator is made to speak of his
betters I think we should should be as
suspicious as when jellus caused skipio
Africanus to use the term Imperium to
refer to Empire that is if other other
things about the qu in the in the case
of gellius when gellius attributes to
people in the second century language
that is simply totally implausible in
one sentence I think we can that we
should be deeply suspicious about the
rest of the fragment there's more we
could discuss here
obviously now before I proceed with the
rest of um before I proceed to the the
the next part of the paper I want to
offer a caveat regarding evidence I'm
not going to survey publicly to which
I'm going to apprend a caution about the
content of that evidence namely the
so-called fragments of the Roman
historians now it may well happen that
the content of one or another fragment
of an historian is going to destabilize
the empirical basis of my project but I
think some caution is in order here very
few fragments of the Roman historians
contain the actual words of earlier
writers
more importantly Romans of nearly every
period wrote on the Assumption of a kind
of homomorphy over time at the level of
both practices and institutional
Arrangements this was part of the point
of telling history of writing history in
the form of lists like
FY they both organized memory and they
asserted a kind of unspoken continuity
in institutional
operations what is taken for granted
when we say that we have always elected
cils and indeed that we know who they
are Roman historians were therefore not
historicists their intuitions will have
been to assume continuity along more
axes of social practice than we would do
in consequence Roman historians cite
earlier historians largely as it regards
points of agreement or disagreement on
matters of detail because each
generation is taken by later generations
to have inhabited the same Rome as they
did did and their narratives are
represented and their texts are
paraphrased on this
assumption if an historian of the late
Republic or an Augustine historian cites
an earlier analyst as if that person
narrated Roman history as a history of
laws one's going to have to be very
careful I think um how about in um in
assessing how much agreement and of what
kind and regarding what matters is being
asserted by that
citation finally it matters to the
broader claim I'm making um that his
historians in the ancient world were
generally not conditioned to see absence
as evidence in Reading their
predecessors they will have been
triggered by patterns other than those
that demand our
attention but we are not
they and so we are free to ask I think
we are called upon to ask whether the
absence of evidence in this particular
case is evidence of something what does
it reveal and what is entailed by our
answer to that
question so far as I can tell no writer
in the second century BC found it useful
to cite or even to refer to written
legislation that originated prior to the
2 century
B.C despite this silence on the part of
authors jurists and orators for the
duration of the 2 Century the fullsome
cataloges of earlier legislation that
one one can compile from later
literature
from ciso Livy and so on demand that we
believe something like the
following throughout the second century
BCE secure data regarding the long
history of Roman legislation was
available and reliable it simply went
uncited by anyone but was accurately
preserved and then it was recovered in
the age of Salah or whenever it was that
we begin to see it cited and when this
whenever this occurred the historical
dat data were reported in a fullsome and
disinterested
fashion this picture of the transmission
of knowledge is exactly as plausible as
the data that Augustus recovered when he
himself did
research and read the speech of matelis
macedonicus on the duty to produce
children or found linen books in the
recesses of temples containing rules on
the celebration of
triumphs I'll say a bit more about these
kind of episodes in Roman scholarship
later now a minimalist conclusion that
we might draw from the pattern silence
in our sources to it from the absence of
evidence for earlier law during the 2
Century BCE is that no written
legislation survived from the earlier
period into the 2 century and this is
why titles are known in the first
century but more or less no
language for my part I urge a maximalist
position written legislation from before
200 BCE was not known in the 2 Century
because it never existed in the first
place institutional um institutions of
communal decision-making surely existed
the assembly made decisions but these
were by and large not written
down now it would take some time to lay
out all the grounds for skepticism that
one might site regarding the knowledge
that the Romans had of their own past
and I should stress you know there lots
and lots of people have written
beautifully and at length about the Reas
the reasons to be skeptical about um the
history of the of the early and middle
Republic um and at some level the field
oscillates over time in 20 or 25 year
increments about just how much credly we
stand extend to this information I'm not
the first person to compile these
passages so I should add right I should
insist all modern historians are aware
of the extent to which their sources
have been EXP exposed as chimerical I
think we just oscillate in our
unwillingness to draw the conclusions
that our methods
demand so let me cite only the most
famous cautions offered to us by the
Ancients themselves I commence with
Cicero's Brutus discussing the Legends
invented and rehearsed within
aristocratic
houses and yet these eulogies have made
the record of Rome's history more
unreliable since they include many
things that did not happen false
triumphs exaggerated numbers of
consulships even false genealogies and
transfers to the plebs merging people of
lower standing with another family of
the same name as though I were to claim
descent from the Manus tulus who was a
patrician conso with servus opius in the
10th year after the expulsion of the
Kings when I say the Legends invented
and rehearsed within aristocratic houses
I mean of course something like the
totality of raw material available to
the historical tradition as they
understood it
alongside this one might cite Livy's
digression on the reliability of
evidence available to him which runs
along very similar lines as he
confronted problematic data in the
history of the samite
wars nor is it easy to prefer one
narrative or one authority over another
historical memory has been contaminated
I think by funeral orations and lying
inscriptions beneath portrait busts as
every family through deceitful lying
appropriates to itself High offices and
noteworthy
achievements certainly it's from this
cause that the Deeds of individuals and
records of public actions have been
confused nor does any writer survive who
is contemporary with these times on on
whom one might reasonably rely as a
reliable
source General statements like these
should be read alongside Livy's repeated
cautions that even in regard to second
century events and personages the
accounts and evidence available to him
were radical disagreement we're now
talking about Livy on the second century
this not Livy on some episode in Hy
Antiquity many other things concerning
particularly the end of Skip's life his
trial his death funeral and tomb pull in
opposite
directions so that I do not know which
repor or which writer I should follow
there is no agreement as the accuser
some write that Marcus Naas others that
the PTI accused him there's no agreement
about the timing nor about the trial nor
about the year when he died nor about
where he died or where he was buried
some say he died and was buried at Rome
others at lerum in both places monuments
and statues are on
display this isn't the effing body of
arrestes this is a person who lived in
real historical time and they got a clue
where his body
is Livia is similarly at a loss
regarding the death of Claudius marcelus
where he follows Kus and Tipper at least
far enough to say that the account left
by marcellus's own son who was an
eyewitness to his father's death um was
implausible
and frankly may be true but
um but perhaps the most important such
remark on Livy's part concerns the
supposed prosecution of Africanus for
which Livy had the evidence of a fake
speech attributed to Africanus and a
fake speech attributed to
graas nor is the disagreement only among
writers of history the speeches too if
they are in fact what they are said to
be namely those of puus skipio and
Tiberius Gras are inconsistent with each
other the title of the speech of pipio
has the name of Marcus nvus the Tribune
is accuser the speech itself is without
the name of the accuser now it calls him
a scoundrel now a
trifler nor does even gras' speech make
any mention at all of the PTI as
accusers of Africanus or of the
prosecution blah blah blah an entirely
different story must be put together
consistent with gras' speech and those
writers must be followed and so on
in other words the Exton speeches are
taken by Livy as serious evidence
despite having no plausible authenticity
the speech of graus I think is clearly a
declamation but Livy then tells you that
he accepts it as the plausible plausible
document among this array and he allows
that it's going to be the north star
that shapes how he writes his Narrative
of the
event regarding the specific lessons we
might draw from these remarks and others
in this vein I can do no better than
quote the reprimand Fergus Miller
offered to Mid Republican historians a
generation ago I'm I look out at
Republican historians feeling like I'm
I'm just doing what Miller did I'm like
I wandered into Republican history from
the Empire and I'm saying stupid stuff
but I'm going to read out what Fergus
said
anyhow we tend to insist not only on
knowing too much but on knowing
precisely those things which the ancient
sources themselves in their better
moment moments warn us that we cannot
know that is to say the attribution to
datable individuals of particular
actions and achievements and the
grouping of individuals into supposedly
reliable family
trees now regarding what I have termed
their sources in
quotes we must always remember that the
Romans saw fit to build a standard set
of FY a continuous record of holders of
high office only in the last decade or
so of the
Republic the infrastructure to date
things even in the most rudimentary
terms which perforce amounted to the
data by which laws might be named and
placed in time because of the way the
Romans named laws did not exist in
vernacular form until after Cicero wrote
de republ because as Cicero wrote de
republ he was still writing to atus to
verify Consular dates about events in
that work as also in the
Brutus the existence of a complete list
of consules was more than a condition of
possibility for the form of the state
that the Romans claimed for themselves
and the kind of narrative through which
they told their
story there W it's weird it changed on
the one screen before it changed on the
other the fleshing out of peacee
knowledge by the by the attribution of
fictive consulates to the same GES over
and over again is frankly why we have
laws in duplicate or
triplicate
right it is emphatically not
true that the Valerie had a fondness for
were quote unquote known for sponsoring
laws de provocon which is a sort of
you're frequently told in Roman
histories in the literature the
existence of the laws is taken to
establish an association between the
family and the cause which Association
is then cited in pure circularity to
defend the reality of of any one law but
this is completely
ridiculous the laws were
straightforwardly a byproduct of the
invention of the
fosy once once you actually wrote down
the
fosty in something like the 40s
BC right and there is no evidence that
they had any written record of any fosty
before the 2 Century BC right once these
were once you populated your madeup list
with valious
the answered to the question which
valious was it that proposed Alex
Valerio de provocon it was obvious each
of them
did now it's precisely for this reason
that it was during the lifetime of
Cicero or just before that we begin to
see inklings of the legal culture that
will flourish
thereafter commencing perhaps from the
age of numantia narratives begin to
appear of the middle Republic that
contain doublets of later events meaning
that a past was being invented or at
least was then being narrated in such a
way that the language and Norms relevant
to some contemporary issue were being
discovered in the past which thereby
became available as Norm in the present
a treaty made inui is not binding usest
C populis ner us it and all these kind
of things in contemporary language that
are then attributed to people of the mid
Republic
this material Aggregates in an
accelerating way and is finally granted
unassailable Prestige and normative
power when Augustus discovered in the
so-called Republican
constitutionalism by which I mean late
late late late Republican
constitutionalism the foundations of
monarchy it was during the reign of
Augustus and not earlier that parties on
all sides seized on public law as the
lens through which to construct a past
that was continuous with the present we
were always is already a polity ordered
by law by way of establishing a new
language of politics for the age of
Republican
monarchy the dates the debates that
issued in the misnamed lexe imperio
espani and the records in that are
preserved the records of votes that are
preserved in the commentar of the Aral
Brethren are the best evidence of
this the same might be said of these um
researches of Augustus that I that I
cited earlier um that is to say his
claim that he discovered as speech of
the censor quintis kilus matelis on the
duty to marry and bear
children now before I make some
concluding remarks a word is in order
about the 12 tables the one early law
whose words or I should say some of
whose words um Romans of the first
century BCE claim to
know I'm
skeptical for one thing as we've seen
several Romans tell us that their own
knowledge of events before the
hannibalic war were deeply
insecure and all Romans repeatedly
demonstrate the truth of this through
sheer not citing and apparently not even
knowing any words of any document
outside of treaties from the first 500
years of the
Republic except for the 12
tables which
although as a preview for tomorrow Seth
told me I may be wrong about this
but which I think goes uncited for at
least 250 years
before suddenly deeply secure knowledge
of the 12 tables and no intervening
document suddenly
emerges now if there's an argument to be
made for the existence of the 12 tables
it would have to Center on later n
narratives of something like early
hermeneutic projects in particular the
tri partita of sexus IAS which might
suggest that something called the 12
tables already existed or was invented
Circa 200 BCE but if Even This Much is
True IAS failed because no author for
the next 100 years cited either the 12
tables or for that matter ilias's own
work two remarkable scholarly projects
have been devoted to the 12 tables in
recent years the one led by florana Cory
and the stunning edition of Michelle
umber I don't wish rashly to Discount
their work but I think we need more than
the testimony of Cicero that the tables
was a necas Arium Carmen alongside
rather oddly a reference to the
legislation of Solon of all things to
prove that this was not in essence a
collective invention of many parties of
the late 3rd Century bcee if not as I
happen to think an invention of the age
of
numantia so I conclude with remarks on
quick remarks on three topics legal
history their Sciences of history and
ours and the Roman state in the 2
Century
BC now regarding legal history
no Roman statute nor practically any
document produced and authorized by the
institutional Machinery of the Roman
State survives in a contemporaneous copy
from before the end of the hok
war later Roman writers which is to say
Roman writers writing much later say
that such statutes existed but they cite
neither the language of such statutes
nor do they provide the a plausible
account of any institution of knowledge
transmission that would explain how they
got supposed knowledge I suggest to you
they did not
exist virtually nothing perhaps in
actuality nothing of what the later
literary sources say about the history
of law before the hannibalic war is true
certainly there is no evidence of any
kind that corroborates their claims nor
any plausible evidence for a mechanism
by which knowledge was preserved and
passed down to suggest how authors in
the later 1st century B.C might have
learned of such documents in believing
them we give our Credence to
Legend in support of this claim I've
cited the writers of Statute they were
themselves practitioners of a kind of
legal history and they cite no law
before 149
BC to put the matter another way I
suggest to you that the pattern of
survival regarding evidence for written
Roman statutes is not happen stance
rather the history um our our extent
Corp of his described Roman laws
reflects the actual history of
legislative enactment fairly
accurately in this light what is perhaps
most stunning about the later 2nd
Century BCE is how rapidly certain
formal aspects of the writing of law
consolidate alongside intellectual
resources related to theed predictable
use of written law savings Clauses that
is um you know places in a statute where
you say nothing in this statute is taken
to contravene Clause X of this earlier
statute which is most of the most of the
occasions when laws are cited in the
exent legislation they take the form of
savings Clauses savings Clauses are a
noteworthy case in point conventional
cools of statutory interpretation are an
obvious example of the
second law once written created its own
reality new histories of Roman law
should tell that
story it happens to be one for which we
have some
evidence among the inventions of the the
later tradition is the so-called Lexi
boua the law that is credited with
introducing the formulary
procedure non- lawyers out there won't
care about the Lex IA but um but you'll
just indulge me please for a
moment as I've stressed the Romans did
not know the identity of the person who
proposed this law or the date or a
single word of its language despite on
their representations it's having
affected a revolution in legal and
social
life this is simply not plausible
if the Lex IIA existed the most
plausible reason for its light footprint
in later memory is that it changed
nothing I it was just
forgettable this brings me to my second
topic which is the science of History
theirs and
ours one thing the Lexi budia did not do
is overturn some earlier World in which
civil procedure operated so rigidly that
litigants who misspoke a word of their
script lost their case I return now to
that quotation from gaos about the
trees this model of archaic law is
delivered to us principally by gaos but
also by
jellas modern legal historians who are
desperate for these stupid anecdotes to
be true never Tire of praising gas as
having had historical interests and
therefore um since he was a historian he
preserved for us we can believe his
evidence um despite its being something
like our only knowledge of pre-form
procedure
what reason do we think gaas had
reliable sources for this information
none on the contrary his claims about
early Roman law sound exactly like other
nonsense P forward by antiquarians in
the 2 Century BC as they speculated
about how different how wildly crazy
were the lives of archaic versions of
themselves for example to Adu an to
bring on some evidence from another
moment in my life
we are told nearly the same thing about
the punctiliousness of Roman ritual inp
of
religion if a Roman got a gesture wrong
or misspoke a word or lacked an
ingredient or an errant noise was made
during the ritual you had to restart the
whole damn thing from the
beginning the Romans even gave this
performance a name it was called an
insto but this is a complete fabrication
of the antiquarian tradition it's it is
virtually without evidence from actual
practice and even from Roman um from
Norms um from from extant Le
Sakai among other things in these extant
leay Sakai we have inscribed rules that
regulate the substitution of one
ingredient for another so if you didn't
have the ingredient you just use
something else we know formula which are
again preserved that you could utter by
way of declaring that an error error in
performance was without ritual
significance if something went wrong you
just said let it let you use the third
person imperative let it be held to have
been performed correctly and you just
went on with your
life and so on punctiliousness of this
kind in which you then redid the whole
expensive ritual was something that one
attributed to one's ancestors by way of
imagining an earlier age of
rectitude but we have we decline to
admit this because we have our own
longing in many ways mematic of theirs
to know a world when men were men and
Roman culture was
pure another comparanda exists in Ply's
history of Roman portraiture just just
by way of I me you could really go on
for a long time about silly things
Romans say about earlier versions of
themselves right um what I call Ply's
spinal tap theory of Roman artart right
this is a a joke about the the little
Stonehenge that appears in spinal tap
right because according to plenty early
Roman portrait statues were about a
meter
tall now it's not entirely clear how
plyy imagines these statues to have
functioned were early Romans very short
and these were just naturalistic
representations were statue bases very
tall instead of situating this passage
alongside others in which antonine
Romans speculate about the smallness or
meanness or so on of early
crafts and instead of just bursting with
laughter one finds an amazing number of
claims that plyy probably found this
data in Vero who might well have known
people who reported on this statuary V
autopsy that's said we've just generated
this way of of of of of insisting that
their knowledge must be true because
it's the kind of thing we would like to
know finally let me say as regards the
Roman state so my final topic as regards
the Roman state in the 2 century B.C
it's not simply that written documents
start to survive in great number after
the hannibalic war so do near something
like contemporary literary accounts
about the production of further
documents that do not
survive as it happens virtually the same
pattern holds for decrees of the Roman
senate this is not accidental and in
that case too I suggest that the pattern
of surviving evidence of inscribed
evidence Maps the history of the
production of written senatorial decrees
more or less
precisely this pattern could issue from
many factors some of which are not
mutually exclusive that is to say the
pattern in our data is not likely to
have a single cause but two significant
patterns in the content of this material
are worthy of remark one a great deal of
the extent material arises through the
recourse of foreigners to the Roman
senate as a forum for dispute
resolution
this process clearly impelled the
development of procedural means to
conduct hearings in what we might call a
rationalized fashion as well as the
development of documentary means to
represent those hearings and their
outcomes in a distinct social elect and
on a distinct
medium this is as it were a corollary to
a pattern I mentioned earlier which is
the one kind of document that the Romans
may have written before the holic war or
treaties because there was a foreign
counterparty so it was it was the
foreign counterparty that generated the
need to produce this thing in a
permanent
form second the Senate is not suddenly
visible in foreign affairs which is to
say the Affairs between states it is
also suddenly visible guiding the
conduct of
magistrates what is more this pattern
the sudden interference of the senate in
what particular senators were doing
finds a correlate in data provided by
literary sources with a kind of claim to
veracity regarding recourse of members
of the Roman Elite to the people namely
to legislative assemblies to Trump the
success of Rivals within the
senate in other
words Senate and commission to use a
Fergus Miller like phrase Senate and
commission are quite suddenly on record
frantically busy on record directing the
activities of elected officials via
legislative
instruments although they appear in
narrative as competing sources of
authority uced by rivals in any given
contest I think the activities of Senate
and commission should in fact be
understood as mutually
constitutive they rise to prominence as
competing sources of law because the
nature of domestic Elite political
competition was rapidly changing in part
of course in response to the changing
conditions of
Empire it lay in the nature of elite
competition that neither institution was
allowed a monopoly the recourse of one
person or group or faction to the Senate
provoke their Rivals to turn to the
people and vice
versa but there is another level in
which competition in this case
competition between sources of law both
constitutes a space and monopolizes it
the performance of
contestation operates so as to convey
the impression by virtue of its noise
and nature that it exhausts and covers
the full Terrain of plausible
positions the performance of competition
among sources of law thus work to
exclude voices in issues not allowed
into their staged
cacophony in short when properly staged
competition among the elite assists in
sustaining the elite as a whole as an
elite turning to the Senate and
commission I suggested a moment ago that
neither obtained a monopoly as a source
of law in this period instead you might
say duopoly was the dominant form of
Monopoly in 2 Century
Rome but a second order effect of
conducting and constraining Elite
competition through legislative
enactment was an intense and sudden
diificult
in the language of salest which was
echoed by Augustine and affirmed by
makavelli the virtue of the elite was
expressed in a desire to dominate and
the project of Empire issued from a
compromise whereby the desire to
dominate was directed not at the masses
at Rome but outward to enemies further
and further a
field in consequence a notable feature
of Roman Republican politics was that
competition among the elite for Prestige
and office took place to a very large
degree outside of Rome it would not be
wholly wrong to say that for a very long
time Roman Foreign Affairs were an
epiphenomenon of domestic
politics in the aftermath of the third
Punic War and increasingly across the 2
Century BC the diversity and size of the
Empire affected an inversion in these
priorities it was tb's argument that the
hannibalic war was decisive in this
transformation the substance of Any
Given debate to one side the effects of
this are visible in the sudden
subordination of priorities in the give
and take of politics to the demand of
collective constituencies for
predictable institutional operations in
the light of vernacular understandings
of what we might term second order or
public
goods not only did magistrates have
henceforth to be constrained in their
conduct Vis conduct of politics viav one
another but one could simply no longer
assume a homology between the aggregated
desires of individual members of the
elite for Eminence and the larger needs
of the state magistrates had to be
controlled those controls are expressed
in the use of Statute to instruct
magistrates in office in the passage of
statutes on magisterial Malin that gave
Outsiders access to Roman tribunals at
the very end of the century in the
placing of geographic constraints on
magisterial action which amounted to an
incipient project of mapping and
territorializing the
Empire so let me now just um let me
conclude by um gesturing at three
contexts by way of provoking some
conversation um gesturing a context that
should be integrated with the story I've
tried to tell the first is the
historiography of the of the first Punic
War I think it seems pretty clear that
knowledge of the first Punic War was
shaky and contestable already in the
Generation Um of Fabius pictor frankly I
think it's pretty clear that the Romans
themselves knew nearly nothing about
what happened in the f First Punic War
and this would not be possible if the
state were generating loads of written
documents in that
era that said to return to a phrase I
used earlier the performance of
contestation in historiography had
similar effects to those that I describe
in politics the fact that people were
disputing over facts made it appear that
the disputants were arguing about
something that was at least potentially
knowable regarding the change from the
third Century to the second I observed
um as well that whatever the go sorry I
I I want to observe that whatever the
Roman government did in the earlier
period whatever the Roman government did
in the 3r century it Revisited those
processes later in the second when on my
claim the Romans started to use
writing well this is I'll how this is
not the actually I won't go back to the
black blank slide but how else are we to
explain the fact that when the that the
Romans wrote a law on jurisdiction for
Sicily only in the year
132 109 years after they made Sicily a
province or in this case right how are
we um this is a an inscription from
aquala on the occasion of a
supplementary deduction the this this
the settling there of a supplementary
group of colonists in the year 169 tius
anus lcus son of Titus the trium beir he
provided for the construction of this
Temple and dedicated he composed and
delivered laws in three times he
enrolled the
Senate so why is it only in 169 BC on
the occasion of a supplementary
deduction that AA received
laws and of course there's the very
interesting problem that on its own
account Rome only began to write poetry
in 240 and history a generation later
and each of these early Endeavors was in
Greek Rome's first taking up in writing
which is to say its late late late
taking up of writing was nevertheless so
frontal an assault on aristocratic
Prestige that Roman literature had
initially to deny its own
existence thank you very
[Applause]
much than you
very
for continue for about minutes
ination to go ahead and let you the
questions
you thank you
so excuse me you use pass the mic or the
mic the
front
oh is it is it on is it on no yes okay
thank you very much um I was wondering
um since you ended with uh literature
that was sort of where my mind was going
as as you were sort of bringing up your
talk and as you're so focused on the way
in which I guess late Republican and
early Imperial historiography is
dedicated to sort of creating the Roman
p and creating This legal past for the
Romans do you see I guess these early uh
kind of Latin uh text texts that are
arising around the time that you're
theorizing written law to be coming in
like anas's and nales like Naas is pun
like those sorts of Kos origines are you
seeing the development of Latin
literature and particularly this
historiographical ideological literature
as being connected to the legal project
that you are seeing if I understood you
correctly
uh yeah know I'm I I I I'm going to give
only a paral answer I'm not sure I'm
competent and plus there people in the
room who are vastly more comp than I to
to answer that um
uh
um so one quick answer the the I I I I
made these gestures at the end in part
because I had some conversation with
friends about about this paper I you
know I I showed it to some Italian
friends I sent it off to Jim
zetel say Jim is this is this dumb is
Jim who really wants to believe in
ilias's tre partita and because I have
such great respect for Jim zetel that I
that I said yeah maybe sexus IAS had a
copy of the 12 tables I tried also to
make it clear I don't believe that but
Jim does and Jim really knows the
Republic and I do not um uh
so
the I mean I I suppose I I kind of
believe they have to be connected right
and it has something to do with it does
it must have something to do with as I
as you term it something like
aristocratic Prestige um this um
um what I will say um I could try to
give a longer answer but let me just
gesture a kind of way a way of thinking
about the problem um that
um there's an there's a kind of
literature out there in the
world a fun literature a diverse
literature that comes from many
disciplinary viewpoints on um on the
origins of
writing um and the connection between
writing and certain kinds of
institutions of social Authority or
between governmental knowledge so
everything from Jack Jack goodie to Wang
ha Chang um really great stuff um I know
of no comparable literature I know of no
comparable comparative literature on um
on a number of populations cultures
civilizations whatever term you want to
use that we can name that deliberately
did not take up writing that were
surrounded by populations that used
writing and did not um so one could
think about the the the one could think
about um the you know the the the early
Persian tradition right and the the
declining in particular to write down
the avesta but the simple non the simple
non-use of writing for recording in
Persian in particular until this
extraordinarily late moment right um You
can think about the very late um um
introduction of Technologies of literacy
into the Sanskrit tradition which is
very old but not nearly as old as far as
one can tell as the Sanskrit tradition
itself um um and you could say Rome and
and and so there there are at least
three cases that come to mind but there
must be others out there in which these
po these cultures exist surrounded by
other people who use writing and they
insist on not writing um and you know
the the the
co-occurrence use it of you know of this
of the of the use of the Technologies of
literacy for governmental knowledge and
then for these other forms of I don't
cultural production for for lack of a
better word there must be uh there must
be at least one St story to tell about
them that that brings all those together
um I I said that at the end in the hopes
really that somebody else would do that
writing for me I don't I don't have a
great
answer thank
you
sure hello thank you so much this is
really so fascinating um my question is
about um how we slot uh or how you see
Roman law operating before you see
writing coming into it and and sort of
related to that um whether one of the
reasons why we don't see anything really
cited before the hannibalic war is
something to do with what happens in
that war and the sort of massive loss of
life that our sources suggest happened
through that and whether there was some
sort of loss of knowledge perhaps and of
that oral
tradition um
huh
[Music]
uh so I can say something about the
first part of your question what did Ro
how did Roman law function before the um
holic war and uh would just be a total
guess be my guess as opposed to someone
else's guess and uh I suppose I could
Riff on the this kind of question of you
know like trauma violence destruction
property blah blah blah you know only
although I will say that I mean to make
a joke about other people who write
about this sort of stuff I obviously
wter shidel um what we don't see in Rome
is a massive destruction of property
which then issues in a 25y year period
after the hannibalic war when when all
those un every you know like property
regimes in Rome are just vastly more
egalitarian because of you know because
like Elite the elite strangle hold and
ownership was somehow broken so um the
hannibalic war there there are to be
more serious there are areas there are
areas of Roman Life After the hanic War
which do not seem to reflect massive
social trauma I mean there obviously
areas that do
um I assume that Roman law before um
before the formulary system um used
something like a formulary system um
that is to say and by by that what I
mean is um that um uh what happens in a
formulary system there various ways you
could modify this but what happens in
the formula formulary system is you know
the two litigants show up in front
of the person in Authority in the later
case in the classical system a
magistrate who has the right to speak
the law um who's allowed to use DEA um
and they tell their story right and um
um uh they say all sorts of crazy
uh you know about you know um
my neighbor's trees fell into my yard
and then they throw another you know
he's crazy he also does it with his
trash his dog barks all night I can't
they throw all sorts of stuff as people
do when they narrate their own problems
and um when the when the magistrate
produces a formula He In classical Roman
law he produces a decision tree um in
which he Narrows down the entire dispute
to a sentence a very complicated long
sentence in which he says if this then
why and then it there can be a cascading
set of decisions like if this but if
there's an exception go here and no it
looks like it treat right and um uh in
which um both a law a norm is brought to
bear on the problem and the case is rarr
so that only the Salient facts are
mentioned and the job of the judge is to
decide which the facts go this toggle a
toggle B and um I sort of assume that
instead of this silly business in which
there was only five actions in Roman law
and you had you know no matter what your
dispute was over you had to say trees um
then in fact much of what happened
before is exactly what happens in the
formulary system you came up the two
litigant described their problem and um
and somebody and you know what might
have been different frankly is the
existence of lay judges or it could be
that before the Lex I budia it was all
all handled by pontiffs and later was
handled by magistrates except that we
know that there were peders who handled
jurisdiction before the Lexi budia um so
I I just I mean and it's for the reason
that we think we have knowledge of PR
peders with jurisdiction before that I I
I I I I suspect that law on law law law
law pre Lex IIA probably looked
something like the formulary system I
mean despite the the historians of Ro
Roman law love to insist in a kind of
really profound way on the difference
between um uh the cognitio procedure and
formulary procedure and then if you
actually look at the actual conduct of
cognitio procedure it looks an awful lot
like formulary procedure I mean why the
Romans were insistent that as an
ideological matter but
that um again I I I think the the
something like the the Technologies of
procedure Avail from the very few and
some of the I mean now I'm going to say
one last thing that I swear I'll shut up
um the techn the some of the aspects of
this procedure quite I'm going to step
aside from the whole issue the stupid
pontiffs and ritual punctiliousness a
lot of aspects of their procedure are
probably overdetermined by the fact that
um um there were no mechanisms of state
power that that could compel somebody to
participate in civil
litigation right um uh right so if you
wanted to sue your neighbor and he
refused to show up you're basically
screwed and the Romans developed
mechanisms for legally but not
instrumentally there was never a police
officer but there were legal means you
could bring to bear eventually to force
your neighbor to actually show up in
court but for a long time these things
did not exist the Romans clearly date
the the introduction of of these things
extremely late so for a long time you
had the if if if a plaintiff filed a
lawsuit the defendant had to be
persuaded to show up and there is a
plausible case to be made that one of
the re things that one of the reasons
why Roman procedure looks the way it
does is because you had to give the
defendant you had to give the defendant
enough confidence that he'd be willing
to show up at all I I could go on but I
think that aspect is probably much more
interesting and probably also that that
kind of interpretation should be brought
to bear because it's a kind of real
condition that we know something about
rather than this kind of like
mythological nonsense
um thank you so much for the fascinating
talk and I'm I'm very fascinated by this
concept of like myth myth histories that
you talked about and this kind of legal
history in constructing a Roman identity
especially in relation to outside um
foreign forces that they're now coming
into contact with um in the second
century um BCE and I was wondering if
you could talk more about who
specifically do you think the Romans are
talking to um When developing these laws
and also what kind of what kind of
dialogues and messages do you think that
they are trying to um send out to like
these other foreign um these foreign
Nations okay okay
um
uh it's
um about legislation somewhat harder but
I will say let me just say a word
digress to step aside to the other body
of EVS I cited that one could take up
but um which is decrees of the Senate um
uh actually the decrees of the Senate
are an interesting thing to cite in
respect of legal procedure right um if
you if you look at decrees the early
decrees of the Senate um that we have um
almost always concern something like
Foreign Affairs um it so happens that of
course many of them are epigraphically
preserved um in in in in Greek in the
East um and interestingly
um when I said something like they
develop this kind of rationalized means
for represent for representing um
adversarial speech um um they you you
can imagine them looking like two
litigant coming from the court right so
the a sonatus consultant very rapidly
develops this mechanism for saying you
know um these people came before us so
and so you know concerning concerning
the matter at hand said this so and so
concerning the matter at hand said that
concerning the matter which was
immediately prior discussed blah blah
and it goes on and there's all these um
markers and the the speech of the
litigant is always paraphrased in a way
that makes them appear to appear to have
spoken remarkably on point um but um
that's also rationalized in the sense
that so that again um all the chaff
about you know all the things that you
might have imagined that a Greek I'm
supposed to stand in front the all the
all the chaff all the stuff that you can
imagine a Greek oror saying like oh it's
so wonderful be to be before this most
distinguished body and you know blah
blah blah and you know I come here
mindful of the extraordinarily long
history of relations between your city
and M and the fact that you know blah
blah blah we both worship Aphrodite and
all this other crap none of that is in
the represented speech paraphrase speech
in the sonatus consulta if you look at a
sonatus consulta somebody came and said
please allow me to cite the facts
relevant to you know my claim in respect
of the ownership of EGA no no no no no
no no no um uh
um so they you can you can see there
something like um the the technology of
memory that might have that a a
technology of memory that looks must be
homeomorphic with the kind of uh with
what a magistrate was doing when people
brought speech before a court
um
uh so the the sonatus
consultum develops in a way um in a kind
of interesting way right so that uh um
where the technology of the of the
letter right um that goes back from the
the magistrate send back back to the
thing um essentially repeats in a kind
of Interest very different form of
summary the content of whatever thing
you know the Ambassador from Chicago
brought to New Haven um the sonatus
consultum which has to render a decision
on the matter gives an extremely
different summary
um which is um and it's it is I think
the the it is I think the arrival of
foreigners that impelled the creation of
this technology it's I mean it there is
no particular reason to think that
before that moment uh the Romans um had
a particular set of mechanisms for
representing adversarial speech in a
written document um so that that would
be one answer you know about the about
legislation I think it's it's much
harder to tell it is noteworthy that the
story the Romans themselves tell tell
about writing legislation is that they
wandered out to look for models about
how to write it up um um um and that may
be itself a version of one of these
kinds of doublets I suggest um I should
add I know why this thought occurred to
me just now that um you
know the kind of picture I'm presenting
which is a p picture of one kind about
you know what I take to have been a
fairly massive set of changes that I
think probably did take place at the
start of the second century in
consequence of the hannibalic war you
know the Romans did tell a story um
about certain kinds of social
revolutions toal place um as a result of
the opening up especially of of wars in
the East you know and I wouldn't
discount that I'm sure that in a variety
of different ways both as something like
their relationship to um their a new
form of encounter with cultures of
writing but also in respect of of
something like political economy as a
result of the importation of wealth that
some of their historiography about
change in the 2 century is surely
accurate not not everything the Romans
say about their own past is dumbb
would be that would be a takeaway Point
that's not a great answer for your
question I hadn't thought about that
aspect one more
question actually this might be a good
follow on to just your last point just
there and I'm wondering sort of outside
of the realm of civil procedure and
statute law um what we can discern or
you think we can be discerned just about
sort of constitutional order in the
middle Republic or Republic I mean and
whether the sort of uh which is often
Unwritten anyway I mean very little of
the fragments of the 12 tables even have
to do with kind of constitutional law
but from some of the historiography
maybe from pictor whom you mentioned for
instance we get a sense of you know
Consul offices constitutional offices
and um Etc um so yeah so I'm wondering
if that level the Constitutional law you
think what Romans had to say about their
their own constitutional order might be
something about which we have uh
some more ability to discern outside of
the Realms of civil procedure and um and
statute but but just curious your
comments on that uh huh um I'll
make I was about to make some promise
like I'll make twoo quick replies so I'm
not very good at that but I'll um so uh
um two things that seem to be true about
Romans before so there there is one area
of public law where I I think it was
Peter brunt insisted the Romans might
have had real knowledge um in a moment
when Peter brunt I can't find the
passage but I think brunt said somewhere
that he doesn't believe the Romans
actually knew anything about their own
past except possibly um he offers I
think in the in the same paragraph two
possibilities one that they remembered
something about big grants of
citizenship because it was kind of like
a thing for the state to all of a sudden
admit new people actually don't believe
that um but um that the history of the
expansion of the tribal
system um uh that they may have had some
sense right of because it's because the
because of the materiality of the
extension of the tribal system it did
actually right they may have it was easy
to guess in what order the tribes were
added even if you didn't have a
narrative to tell you it would be easy
to guess and what sort of make a guess
what order the tribes are added and blah
blah so that's one thing um I should
mentioned that in the wider context of
what we're talking about the other is
about public law
um I mean two things that do seem to be
true about Roman Public Law which you
can guess on the basis of things that we
might think we me know are these Roman
systems uh something like Republican
principles of um Power relations among
magistrates that one you can protect
yourself from um from errant magistrates
by by having them always be in even
numbers um um um uh and um that is a
kind of principle that they widely
observe so that's a a feature of Roman
public law that I think was probably
true before yet and then um it is
noteworthy I think um uh that a kind of
interesting number of Latin abstractions
that derive from comparatives appear in
the language of government right not
simply mastas but mum ministerium and I
mean I don't know of any other
of Latin in which there's so many
abstractions from comparatives as
Government um and I think this I think a
a lot of what a lot of how they organize
something
like public law which is to say moments
of dispute between magistrates which is
when something would have to be settled
had to do with like um two councils
facing off or having two people argue
and then somebody saying well somebody's
more important somebody's less important
and that was it um uh and um you know
there's a really I mean this is I guess
part of what I mean we might talk about
with Seth tomorrow I might I might be
taken to task but if you look at if you
look at if you look at if you look at
something like Roman
administration of of its of
Italy be before 200 it's their demand
the demands of Roman Administration for
something like a state knowledge
apparatus were astonishingly tiny just
astonishingly tiny I mean you know there
was there was I mean if you name
something that might actually have
existed as opposed to stuff for which we
have virtually no evidence the formula
togot torum right they didn't tax these
all these allies you didn't need to keep
records of property or their riches or
whatever all the kind of later stuff all
the right the form of later governmental
knowledge the application of the census
of all things I mean the census with its
extraordinary ideology as an instrument
for assessing who is a citizen and not
the moment when you start applying the
census to foreigners is an extraordinary
ideological moment but it has a other
things to do with the fiscal demands of
the state and the way in which we're now
taxing
people right but before before before
you know before some date the Roman
demands on subjects of Rome especially
in Italy were amazingly primitive and I
think I mean by primitive I mean they
they their the the knowledge needs of
these processes were incredibly
few I mean that's a just come back to
Public Law I mean later they later
public documents of the state um which
are co-related to functions right in
general in spite of Andrew rsby the
Roman State didn't go nuts for writing
down unless it needed the knowledge
or unless having the knowledge had some
really symbolic relationship to an
important function of government
regardless whether it was actually used
but the the Roman state in the third
Century what knowledge knowledge was not
knowledge didn't was not an instrument
of power I think in the you know in the
in the early woman State now it's that
doesn't believe me at all now now I've
really I I tried I tried in writing the
paper I knew I I knew particularly you
know particularly with um with Chris
being here and um you know and and Seth
I really didn't want to say something
stupid about early Republican Latin or
for that matter about the the Roman
State before 200 but now I've gone and
done it so so you can see the
conversation's not over as has been
alluded to A Thousand Times we'll
continue tomorrow morning at 9:00 a.m.
in Phelps Hall 401 we have three
distinguished speakers in our company
among whom is Seth Bernard he's been
alluded to and pointed at mentioned a
number of times a major expert in
Republican Roman history he's joining us
from the University of Toronto we also
have Emily Kurt um who is joining us
from John Kat University in Rome and uh
is a recent PhD of this program but also
has tremendous knowledge of the
Republican perial and finally RAF
current graduate student who's studying
Roman law more in the Imperial period
but I think has lots to contribute too
all these people will comment on and
then discuss the paper with Professor
Ando please join us if you will um and
uh in the meantime though I had promised
riches we have seen that riches were
delivered in the good about riches they
paid dividends in the form of food and
drink we can go over to the Union League
and the above uh uh the Second Story um
uh party room as it were and continue
the conversation over some nice nibbles
and drinks but first let's give our
speaker a round of
[Music]
applause